>>> DRAG QUEENS AND THEIR ILK
SHUT DOWN BY AN ANGRY.
THAT IS CUTE.
IOWA PARENTS, MY FAVORITE KIND,
OR AFTER A LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL
ALLOWED DRAG QUEENS TO PERFORM
FOR STUDENTS.
THAT'S THE KIND OF PERVERSION
THEY SHOULD KEEP INSIDE THE
FACULTY LOUNGE.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE THEIR TAX
DOLLARS WERE HARD AT WORK.
DON'T REWARD ME.
THIS HIGH SCHOOL.
I BET I AM SAYING THIS WRONG
BECAUSE IT'S PROBABLY NEVER BEEN
SAID OUT LOUD BEFORE.
HELD AN AFTER HOURS EVENT LAST
SPRING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
SCHOOL'S GAY STRAIGHT ALLIANCE.
ACCORDING TO A LOCAL PAPER THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SIGNED OFF ON
INVITING PERFORMERS FROM THE
IOWA YOUTH PARADE PAGEANT.
THEY DID NOT APPROVE THE DRAG
SHOW.
YOU CANNOT.
THAT'S SOMETHING I LEARNED THE
HARD WAY.
TOOK ALL MY CLOSE.
LEFT ME ON THE SIDE OF THE ROAD.
IT WAS A GLORIOUS TWO HOURS.
WALKING HOME IN THE SON.
WHERE AM I?
NOW ONE MOM HAS HAD ENOUGH.
KIMBERLY SHOWED UP TO A SCHOOL
BOARD MEETING WEARING THE SAME
LEOTARD OUTFIT AS THE DRAG
PERFORMER.
HERE IS WHAT SHE SAID.
>> DOES THIS OUTFIT MAKE YOU
TURN YOUR HEAD?
DOES THIS OUTFIT SEEM
APPROPRIATE FOR ANYBODY HERE TO
SEE?
BECAUSE IF IT MAKES YOUR HEAD
TURN AND THIS MIXES YOU UP, IT
SHOULD.
>> CAN YOU ADDRESS?
>> I WOULD COMPLEMENT HER JUST
TO BE SAFE.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT RESPONDED TO
THE INCIDENT IN A STATEMENT
SAYING, THE DISTRICT RECOGNIZES
THE IMPORTANCE OF CITIZEN
PARTICIPATION AND ENCOURAGES THE
COMMUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
DISTRICT MATTERS.
BEYOND THAT THE DISTRICT IS
FOCUSED ON IMPROVING OUTCOMES
FOR OUR STUDENTS AND REMAINS
COMMITTED TO THAT GOAL.
THAT WAS GREAT.
DID THE MOTHER'S STUNT WORK?
IF IT WERE TO GET DRAG SHOWS OUT
OF THE SCHOOLS, IT'S TOO EARLY
TO TELL.
BUT IF SHE WANTED DADS TO ATTEND
SCHOOL MEETINGS.
THERE IS AN INTERESTING POINT
HERE THAT I THINK SHE IS MAKING.
IT IS NOT REALLY JUST A STUNT.
IT'S REALLY PERCEPTIVE THAT IF A
WOMAN, A BIOLOGICAL WOMAN SHOWED
UP IN SCHOOL AND DID SOMETHING
LIKE THAT, LIKE LET'S SAY
STRIPPING WITHOUT GETTING
COMPLETELY NAKED, BUT STRIPPING.
THAT WOULD BE UNACCEPTABLE.
BUT BECAUSE IT HAS A MEASURE OF
INTERSECTIONALITY.
IT'S A MAN AND SOMEHOW
CONSIDERED AN ART FORM.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT.
SHE MADE HER POINT.
SHE COULD HAVE DONE A BETTER JOB
CONVEYING IT IF SHE HAD DONE THE
CLASSIC DRAG QUEEN DEATH DROP
WHICH IS ONE LEG OF AND ONE LEG
BACK AND YOU GO ON YOUR BACK.
OR THE FLYING LEAP INTO A SPLIT
AND YOU LAND ON THE GROUND.
THE FELLOWS WILL COME CALLING IF
YOU CAN LEARN HOW TO DO THAT.
I LOOKED AT THAT AND THOUGHT I
AM NOT A PARENT.
I WONDERED WHAT THE KIDS ARE
LOOKING AT ON THEIR PHONE IF THE
PARENTS ARE WORRIED ABOUT THIS.
I LOOKED AT THAT OUTFIT AND SAID
SHE LOOKS GREAT.
SHE COULD GO OUT TO A BAR IN
THAT.
IT LOOKS LIKE A GYMNASTICS
LEOTARD ANYWAY.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
I'M DISGUSTED.
WHAT IS WRONG WITH YOU?
>> I LOVE DRAG QUEENS.
>> STOP IT WITH THEIR DRAG QUEEN
PRODUCING.
>> I ALSO NEED TO WHERE FAKE
HAIR, FAKE LASHES AND A BIG
PADDED BRA TO LOOK NOTICEABLY
FEMALE.
I HAVE A LOT IN COMMON WITH
THEM.
>> A DRAG QUEEN, I LOOK LIKE A
MAN WITHOUT THE HELP OF DRAG
QUEENS DOING MY MAKEUP AND I
WENT INTO A DEPARTMENT STORE
ONCE AND I HAD PLUCKED OUT ALL
OF MY EYEBROWS.
A DRAG QUEEN HELPED ME AND TOLD
ME TO STOP PLUCKING MY EYEBROWS.
YOU LOOK INSANE.
AND SHE FILLED MY EYEBROWS AND.
>> THEY ARE LIKE LITTLE ANGELS.
THEY TRY TO HELP YOU.
>> IF I TRIED TO WHERE THAT
OUTFIT THEY WOULD SAY IT'S A
DRAG QUEEN AGAIN.
>> DRAG QUEENS DO EXAGGERATE THE
FEMALE FORM, WHICH IS KIND OF
INTERESTING.
I WANT TO ASK THIS.
ANSWER IT SOMEWHAT SERIOUSLY AND
DON'T TRY TO WORK IT INTO A
PROMOTION FOR YOUR RAZORS.
>> I TAKE THE POINT AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR SOME OF THE
SHAMELESS PLUGS I DID EARLIER.
LET ME JUST CHECK MY NOTES REAL
QUICK.
THE THING THAT I FIND
INTERESTING ABOUT DRAG QUEENS IS
I HAVE LIVED IN NEW YORK CITY
FOR MANY YEARS.
I CAN COUNT ON ONE HAND HOW MANY
DRAG QUEENS I HAVE RUN INTO.
SOMEHOW IN MIDDLE AMERICA THIS
IS THE BIGGEST THING.
YOU GO IN CHILES ON A TUESDAY
NIGHT AND YOU COME DOWN WITH THE
FAJITA PLATE.
>> THIS IS A NEW THING.
I WANT TO KNOW WHEN DID IT
BECOME?
I HAVE NO JUDGMENT ON IT
WHATSOEVER.
I COULD GIVE A [ BLEEP ] .
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE IT
SPONTANEOUSLY ERUPTED AS KIND OF
A MOB VIRTUE SIGNAL KIND OF
PUSHED BY SOME GROUP OR
ORGANIZATION.
I AM NOT SAYING I AM A
CONSPIRACISTS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> A COUPLE THINGS HERE.
I DO HAVE KIDS.
I HAVE A MIDDLE SCHOOL OR AN
HIGHSCHOOLER.
THE HIGH SCHOOLERS WOULD NOT BE
SHOCKED BY THIS AT ALL.
THEY WOULD BE LOOKING AT THEIR
PHONES WATCHING THE EUPHORIA
DURING AND LOOK UP AND SAY GOING
BACK TO THE HBO SHOW.
NUMBER TWO, AS A PARENT, I AM SO
SICK OF SCHOOLS NOT FOCUSING ON
MATH AND READING AND CRITICAL
THINKING.
I REALLY THINK THE ONLY TIME MY
GIRLS LEARN STATE CAPITALS IS
WHEN I HAD HER SHOWER CURTAIN
THAT HAD ALL THE STATE CAPITALS
ON IT.
THEY NEED TO GO BACK AND TEACH
KIDS MATH.
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
THE OTHER THING AS A PARENT I
APPRECIATE THIS STUNT.
WHEN MY OLDER DAUGHTER WAS A
FRESHMAN IN HIGH SCHOOL SHE
TRIED TO WHERE CROP TOPS TO
SCHOOL.
SO I STARTED WEARING CROP TOPS
AND FOLLOWING HER AROUND THE
HOUSE.
THE OTHER DAY SHE CAME HOME AND
I WAS FOLDING LAUNDRY.
I FOUND ON ONE AND PUT IT ON.
I WAS FOLDING LAUNDRY AND SAID
HEY.
SHE SAID WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> I KIND OF LIK